you know to the conversation about money
and wealth it's one being willing to
release a familiar now for an unfamiliar
future that's easier said than done and
it's bigger than it sounds are you
willing to have your future look
unfamiliar and in some cases look around
and you don't recognize anything are you
willing are you so tied to the comfort
of what you know even in a discomfort so
I was willing to reinvent myself a
thousand times are you willing to
introduce yourself to the new version of
You Are you willing to go places you
wouldn't go and do things that you
traditionally wouldn't do see I wasn't
traditionally in meditation or in
visualization or hanging around older
white men or like I had a thousand
things that I didn't do traditionally to
change your life you have to be willing
to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing
different things
as you will stay stuck forever I was
doing an Instagram live yesterday with a
young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content and some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of this what it is you're
afraid of being judged and so we're not
comfortable doing that thing you'll
you'll fail if nobody else sees it if
it's just you but you don't want to fail
in front of other people and that can no
longer be a good enough reason because
if you only do think about this if you
only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what do
what you've always done you're going to
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is the thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
as that's not against your value system
right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I wanted to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 when we hit
23 cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know a quarter of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
the willingness to show up even if you
don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today looked the same as yesterday look
the days the day before same as the day
before is why most people do not like
their life is why most people drive to a
job that they hate
they're driving to a job to the hate
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing
now try to get to the reason behind the
reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I wanna I wanna be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I don't have the time I don't have
the camera I don't have the gear I don't
have the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we were afraid of when people won't
watch it and what does that mean you
know that you suck and the people will
watch it and laugh at you or criticize
you for having a bad phone bad camera
bad microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
of failure if it's fear of not being
good enough if there's fear of being
imposter if it's fear of being
uncomfortable whatever your actual fear
is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
so catch what your trigger word is and
I'd love to even know in in the comments
below if you want to leave what is your
trigger word that when you say it when
you text it when you think it when you
feel it that has been holding you back
and that you no longer wanted to
so let's put it in the chat and let's
relieve
a little bit of that pressure that that
word holds over us
so you can actually go build the life
that you want
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I love this question I don't think I've
ever been asked this question before
I've never had an opportunity to explain
it being the best version of you first
of all it's not don't think of it
holistic I want you to break it down to
different parts of your life because
when you are committed to being the best
version of you which in summary it's the
you that you're so incredibly proud of
holistically it's a 360 approach it says
I'm not perfect
so Beth does not mean the perfect
version of you because I think
Perfection and balance are two illusions
that are designed to help you keep
chasing something that's not even
attainable so perfect is not attainable
and balance is not attainable so it's
perfectly managing my imperfection and
releasing balance and having Harmony
number one
but the best version of you is really
saying that in each area of my life I'm
in movement in each area of my life I'm
an evolution in each area of my life I'm
active I am actively participating in an
upwardly way in an upperly mobile way in
this area of my life times every area of
my life it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're always where you want to be but
it does mean that you're being
responsible you're being active and
you're being proactive finances that
you're looking at your numbers just this
morning just this morning I ran my
credit score again I want to see what's
on it I want to be actively
participating in my financial growth I
looked at my savings I looked at my life
insurance I just looked at my my
long-term plan not necessarily because I
want to buy another house or I want to
buy a car I just want to be on top of it
I want to be responsible for it and then
health and wellness Jesse yesterday I
was talking to Matt and going Matt it's
time for us to do another health and
wellness campaign I don't I don't
necessarily want to do it and it's
slightly to moderately scares me a bit
when I'm bringing my fitness into a
public conversation but I know the
responsible me the best version of Lisa
is saying hold me accountable hold me
accountable to my fitness goals hold me
accountable to my Total Wellness goals
and then last week I was just sitting
with someone saying you know what I need
to go down the list of all the checkups
that I've had I need to make sure I'm
not missing anything
relationships I just said to a
girlfriend yesterday hold me accountable
hold me accountable to not running
I realize that I run well and I run
smoothly I run like a gazelle sometimes
when it comes to relationships you don't
it doesn't even look like I'm running
because I'm so busy so I asked someone
who knows me who knows the love that I
want who knows my sexy excuses
I need you to hold me accountable when I
say this I want you to question it and
so while there's so much growth in every
era of my life I'm being the best
version that I know to be because I'm
active in every single area I'm not
saying I'm being the best or I am the
best please don't get me wrong with that
I'm just saying to be the best version
of myself so when you look at being the
best version of yourself look at each
part of your life and go what am I
actively doing where you feel like I'm
in the game in this area I'm not
resigned and I'm not praying for it to
go right or I'm not in resignation and
in complaint about it I'm not a victim
to that relationship I'm not a victim to
my finances I'm not a victim to the
relationships in my family I'm an active
part of creating what's occurring and it
can always get better but I'm an active
part that's being the best version of
you and waking up each morning and
saying I like me today I got many things
I can work on but I like me today before
you ever go out on Facebook or any other
social media platform to check to see if
anyone else like you your job is to like
you first and every other like is bonus
that's stepping into the best version of
you setting long-term goals that make
your knees knock a little bit and make
your teeth chatter a little bit those
goals that you don't know exactly how
you're gonna get it done but it's
something that you want to get done it
doesn't it stretches you but it doesn't
stress you your goals are supposed to
stretch you not stress you
those things that combination and when
you live in that capacity and you focus
and you operate in that one that's when
you're living and being the best version
of you I love to go back and share some
of my favorite memories with you my
fondest and what I realized they're
actually my most moving memories
one happened over 12 years ago I was in
Toronto Canada with Margaret and this
gentleman walked up to me standing about
six foot two Caucasian man in his
mid-40s and he looked at me and he goes
Lisa
I have a problem with you I said you do
and my heart starts to beat I'm like oh
my God someone doesn't like me what did
I say wrong in their eyes and what how
is this gonna play out
and it goes I have a problem I really
have a problem and I said okay how can I
help you he said I'm an atheist I don't
believe in God
I'm fine not believing in God I'm
comfortable I prefer not to believe in
God I don't believe that there's a God
and I said okay
what's your problem he said my problem
is I love you
I love everything about you
I love the energy you come with I love
the way you speak I love what I feel
when I'm listening to you talk
he said and you keep referring to this
God
as your source
and I don't believe in God
so that's my problem
and I said sir I'm sorry
I'm not sure where your problem lies
I said if if you don't believe in God
you have that right
if you love me
I'm excited because you can feel that I
love you too
and he looked at me and he goes so let
me get this straight
this is not the part where you try to
convert me or try to tell me how wrong I
am or you try to explain to me about
your God so that I can begin to believe
like you believe
this is this is not that part you're not
gonna do that
and I looked up at him I said
why would I do that
you're committed to whatever you believe
in my job is to honor your belief system
and he goes see you're doing that thing
again that's making me love you more
that's my problem but I know you believe
in God I said that's not a problem
why don't you keep believing in me and
loving me
I'll keep believing in God and loving
God and we'll keep having this great
experience
after I said that he just grabbed me
and he hugs me
and he held me
and I knew somehow he was holding on to
possibility that's what I choose to tell
myself
he was holding on to the love that he
could feel for me the palatable
non-judgmental
non-persecuting love
and in that moment
I couldn't feel more joy as I held that
man I couldn't feel more joy I I
couldn't feel more happiness that this
is what Ministry is about this is what
touching Souls is about is is to love
the person who thinks that you might not
love them because they're belief system
it was just so beautiful the moment was
so beautiful I mean he held me
and Lenny Drew back and looked at me
said you're the real deal
and I looked up at him
and I said so are you
and we said our goodbyes I never saw him
again Margaret and I went up to the room
our hotel room that night
and replaying what happened we both just
started to ball just cry
and I said to Market Margaret
this is Marketplace Ministry
disguised as a business
[Music]
I'm not in the converting business
I don't need to convert anybody you're
exactly where you choose to be
[Music]
but I am in the loving business
my job is to love you where you are
and that beautiful gentleman
that day
he reminded me and Margaret I believe
what unconditional love could feel like
you know when you want to learn how to
trust your intuition more you know I say
and this is me in my walk and my my
belief system that your intuition is
your internal GPS system your internal
God placement system it's that whisper
and sometimes it's that scream that
tells you to LEAP or to be still your
intuition is a combination of spirit
emotion and logic and it's guiding you
and so often we don't hear our intuition
why don't we hear it because we're
having too much chatter in our head
like the chatter in our head doubt worry
judgment oh my God judgment or fear fear
of other people's perception of you so
your intuition is saying I love to dance
I want to dance I want to sing your
intuition is saying we can have a great
time your intuition is saying I want
love your intuition is saying gosh let's
go take that chance on that writing that
book or let's take that chance on
starting that business then your chatter
comes in no what if I fail so let me
explain this to you your mind your brain
is designed to keep you safe
is designed and it only has the ability
to go back in time in the mental file
cabinet and look at the last time you
tried something like this and it may not
have been
um good or may have ended in some
dangerous situations where people could
judge you and your brain is designed to
protect you that's your brains desire to
protect you it's logical your intuition
is that spark of passion it's that spark
of Desire it's that spark of love it's
that spark of pull me forward it's that
little bit of radical it's that a lot of
bit of of I want to leave my fingerprint
on this planet your brain isn't designed
to have those same ideas now now your
intuition can kick the brain in and the
Brain can start thinking of ways too but
the intuition is where it's going to
start it's in your gut it's why when you
feel something you kind of go here you
don't go oh I feel so special you don't
say I feel special here you say I feel
it here I feel it here and so your job
is not to turn down the doubt your job
is to turn up the passion it's to turn
up the faith is to turn up the
possibility now still make
well-thought-out plans I always say the
best plan is the plan made I don't care
if you have to upgrade it you have to
modify it but if you if you if you if
you fail to plan then you plan to fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow with a plan because that's
where your brain gets excited your brain
goes yeah we got a plan now now you can
believe yourself see you set big goals
and dreams and you have desires and then
you don't achieve it but you don't
achieve it because you didn't set the
plan in place you didn't do the details
and then you stopped believing you could
do it and then you do the biggest
tragedy you stop dreaming
you stop hoping you stop stretching
yourself you stop listening to your GPS
your God placement system that says
you've been put here on a Divine
assignment and your assignment may
change over years guess what your
assignment you had 15 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today your job
is to turn down the volume in your head
the volume of judgment the volume of
fear the volume of worry the volume of
perfection turn down the volume in your
head and turn up the volume in your
intuition in your solar plex in that God
placement system and that heart space
turn up the volume that place that just
says what do I want
what ask yourself this tonight today
tomorrow what feels good to my soul and
then be still and be quiet
I believe I believe in prayer and I
believe in meditation
and I grew up only knowing about prayer
but then I learned that prayer is asking
God or the Divine whatever you call your
god I've not been posing my belief
systems on you but I call them God that
prayer is asking God for direction and
meditation is being still and quiet long
enough to hear the answer
a lot of times we don't hear our
intuitive Spirit talking to us because
we're not still and we're not quiet
long enough to hear it
so give yourself the gift of quiet time
and really after you've asked the
question what brings me joy what excites
my soul what do I want to do for the
next six months or six years what makes
me feel passionate what sets me on fire
and then
be still and then listen but the biggest
question
is will you be bold enough to act on
what you hear
I ain't going nowhere so I want to hear
what happens I want to hear what you
heard I want to hear what came up for
you I want to hear what stirred your
soul I want to hear how excited you got
I want to hear about the feelings that
begin to post your entire body when you
listened to your GPS when you listen to
that calling in your soul I want to know
because that's when the hair on the back
of your neck stands up that's when you
get chicken skin that's when you can't
sleep at night that's when you get up
early I'm just saying I'm just saying I
love the phrase willpower but willpower
isn't something you conjure up willpower
isn't something you drink willpower
isn't something you download from Google
what you're talking about is how do I
make the choices that are in alignment
with my highest purpose and my highest
vision for myself that's what you really
want to ask see your life is a physical
manifestation of the choices that you
made up into this moment I'm gonna say
that again because that gets a little
deep and I can go over some people's
head that can hit you sometimes right
between the eyes and you got to hear the
second time so here it goes your life
right now as it exists today your
finances your weight your relationships
your career your self-esteem your
self-image your spiritual awareness all
of that is a result of the choices that
you've made up into this moment big and
small and just so you know your life the
way it appears today is not a result of
a few big choices even though that's the
thing that we look back on we go oh I
shouldn't have moved out of the state I
shouldn't have got into that
relationship I shouldn't have we look at
the big things well I'm here to disrupt
that mindset a bit your life experience
right now is not so much a result of
your big choices why those impact you
it's really a result of a bunch of small
little choices made consistently over a
long period of time
because those are the habits and the
behaviors that you've gotten into so we
can talk about willpower and how do I
build willpower as if it's something
that you can Flex in the gym or
something you can do crunches or ABS or
triceps and build but it's not the
question you should ask
the answer you should be seeking
is what does it take to make my choices
become an alignment with the life that I
say I want to live
now when you say choices it makes it
really sobering because even when you
choose to sit down on yourself it was a
choice so I ask you in this moment what
will it take you to to decide to make
the choice today don't even think about
tomorrow don't think about next week but
to make the choice today that's in
alignment with your health goals make a
choice today that's in alignment with
your financial goals it's the small
things it's the extra visit to Starbucks
it's the extra biscuit it's the getting
up early it's 10 more crunches it's
doing squats every time you go to the
bathroom at least that's what I do I do
10. I do ten every time I go to the
restroom I'm already there I'm just
going to keep on going just because I
want to stay in alignment with my goal
and my goal is to have a body that at
least
creates a double take
or or triple date maybe I don't know I
wanted to create a body that is in
alignment with my goal I want to be able
to go paintballing with my nephews and
my son the way I just did recently I
want to be able to go jet skiing so when
I look at my life and my lifestyle that
I want to maintain it requires me to
hike a little longer it requires me to
eat more vegetables and protein it
requires me my my choice of how I want
to live requires my alignment and what I
put in my body or how I stay active in
my body so when I date I don't I don't
do dinner dates I'm not interested in
doing dinner dates you want to date me
let's go on a hike let's go skating ice
skating roller skating let's go on a
walk I want active dates in my dating
experience because that's in alignment
with my life's purpose so
what are you choosing let's not even
look at willpower let's look at choices
because choice is something you can
control in every single moment and the
choice you made yesterday if it wasn't
in alignment with your greatest goal and
your highest purpose okay yesterday's
yesterday make a new Choice today you're
not ever condemned or sentenced to
making the same Choice over and over and
over again every day every moment you
have a new opportunity to make a new
choice so divorce yourself from the
conversation that's who I've always been
and divorce yourself from the
conversation well Lisa it's hard yeah
listen mediocracy is crowded everybody's
hanging out in mediocracy but Excellence
world class it's a lot of room up there
so it's only for those who are willing
to be mildly to moderately to maybe
significantly inconvenienced by making
the choice that's in the highest
alignment with the highest version of
themselves so let's just put away
willpower and let's pick up choice and
then let's make a choice that blows your
mind if you find that the relationships
around you have toxic outcomes then I
want you to look at where is the
breakdown is the breakdown in
communication is the breakdown in how
you communicate the words you're using
is the breakdown in who you choose to be
around as the breakdown in the
engagement of what you're talking about
what I've learned is that if you're not
talking about things that are high
enough and big enough things that are
inspiring enough you will slip into the
smallness every single time if you don't
choose an intentionally High evolving
encouraging conversation you will slip
into the cracks you will slip into those
crevices of smallness and Petty and
until you get people trained that you're
going to live up here without telling
them I need you to know it's not an
announcement it's a way of being and so
what do you choose to participate in
it's a stepping over your desire to hear
smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook did you stop the
conversation
did you say hold on I don't want to
engage in speaking negatively of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk at
the risk of losing the relationship but
what you basically do is is you say
here's where I play
here is where I live I'm not visiting
this High Road of Integrity I'm not
visiting this High Road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity
and people I don't visit this place I
live here
I don't visit this place
I live here and in a loving way anyone
that's engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here or they
choose to engage with someone else
now if you find that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger are
you in a moment of resentment are you in
a moment of hurt then you're not living
in your highest Integrity you just visit
every now and again when you come to
this channel uh oh I see my my Shantae
coming out right now Shantae is my
middle name it's what I do when I start
getting real edgy because I really want
you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside and then you don't
leave your conscious neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise and they'll
pick other people to be with and hang
with and I know that sounds easier said
than done because some of the people who
are playing at a lower level might be in
family it might be and that's fine too
you can love people it doesn't mean you
have to spend tons and tons and tons of
time if that time costs you something
spend as much time as you can spend as
much time as serves you spend as much
time as they will allow you to spend but
never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line and supporting you to either
recognize are you the toxic element are
you surrounding yourself in toxic
element it's to make a commitment where
you live
where am I living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what I do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness that's
powerful own it and then go where do I
want to be and then what's the distance
between here and there what do I have to
do to get there or I have to say no to
we'll have to participate in we'll have
to ask forgiveness for we'll have to
clean up what relationships require
cleaning up and then what declarations
must I make
and what decisions must I live in don't
make a decision living your decision let
me first explain to you what forgiveness
isn't because most people won't forgive
because they have an incorrect
understanding of what forgiveness is
so forgiveness is not partnering
someone's Behavior it's not excusing
someone's Behavior forgiveness isn't
admitting that you were wrong
forgiveness isn't saying what was done
to me is okay
forgiveness isn't any of those things
forgiveness actually if you really
understand it it has less to do with the
other person and more to do with you and
more to do with your future let's go
back to the oil and water scenario so
forgiveness invites in love invites in
possibility invites in prosperity it
invites in new thinking it invites in
creativity so forgiveness is an
expanding emotion when you forgive
you're opened up for new things
anger is a Contracting emotion it
requires you to shut down to avoid to
shut out to stop talking everything in
Anger is about stopping and shutting
down everything about forgiveness is
about opening up without pardoning
someone's Behavior I want to make sure
I'm clear on that because most people
attach forgiveness to it but you don't
know what he did but you don't know what
she did when you can detach forgiveness
is not about what they did forgiveness
get this forgiveness is about making
yourself available think about you your
body is primary real estate there's only
so much of it it's a finite it's a
finite
space there's only so much space it's
not forever this is your body this so if
this is your primary real estate if this
is your primary real estate your heart
and you're you have anger occupying 20
of it you can never experience a hundred
percent love you can never experience a
hundred percent possibility you haven't
given yourself a chance at a hundred
percent of the things you want most
because your primary real estate your
heart your body your mind is being
occupied with a very intrusive toxic
emotion
less and less about them
nothing to do with them being right or
their behavior being pardoned or the
action it's your your future is paying
for your past
when you hold on to anger
so when you get really connected to the
cost of anger
then it's not about the what
a matter of fact the longer you've been
angry the longer you've robbed yourself
of a hundred percent of what you were
worthy of and if someone's betrayed you
if someone's hurt you then you over
everyone deserve a hundred percent love
a hundred percent possibility a hundred
percent but it requires forgiveness and
in many cases it's forgiveness of
yourself in many cases the person you've
been angry at the longest is yourself
and the same rule applies when it comes
to you over the years I've had to learn
how to disconnect myself from people
how to pull away how to move on without
what I call Benihana in people now I
don't know if you remember but if you
ever go to a Benihana restaurant they
have those sharp knives and they kind of
go and you don't even know that the
zucchini is like all diced up until they
move it and then everything is cut apart
well
just to have a habit of like cutting
people off so well so fast that I felt
like I benehaunted them like they didn't
know they were like all sliced and diced
until they went to walk away and their
head fell off and then their arms fell
off and I over the years I had to learn
how do I
complete by the way
I would say don't
break up with people don't break away
from people don't
stop being their friends
a better mindset is recognize when the
relationship is just complete
now I say complete say complete with me
when I say complete that means the
relationship has had every experience
that it needs to have you've done
everything you need to do and it's just
complete
so you don't have to make people wrong
that was a big lesson for me because
we're taught that in order for
relationships to end someone's brains
need to be splattered on the ceiling
well
the older wiser me recognizes that I can
end relationships from people who I've
outgrown are people who might be toxic
or people who are just not a fit for me
and also leave their dignity intact
key word I want you to write that down
type that in chat because there is a way
that you can complete with people notice
I'm using these keywords with you you
can complete with people meaning every
experience that we need to have we've
had and now I'm complete
that you can do that and leave their
dignity intact you can say this
relationship has run its course you
don't have to outline everything that's
not working because you know we outline
things that are not working all we're
doing is making people wrong
so let me just say the way you complete
a relationship is to first check your
ego because your ego or ladies your
shego
they will get in the way and what you
want to do is point point point point
point I'm I'm done with you because of
this this and this and we all know when
you point one finger over there the
three fingers point back at you we've
all heard it but more importantly than
that is can you give people the gift if
you're really on this journey called
transformation
can you give people the gift of
completing a relationship with them
while leaving their dignity intact
let me show you how because I had to
learn this one so you want to write this
down
so number one when you go into a
relationship when you when you go into a
conversation number one when you go into
a conversation that needs a course
correction or that you're going to
complete with you don't want to go in
and say I have to talk to you about
something
something isn't working because you're
neutral so you go into that relationship
already at zero you're neutral now
follow me with this you got to really
pay attention so eliminate all
distractions right now
you don't want to go into a relationship
that's going to be difficult at neutral
you want to go into the relationship at
plus plus okay so you might hear some
noise in the background don't worry
about that I'm sitting in my backyard
it's summertime I have kids playing it's
summertime they're free waterfalls are
flowing so I'm not gonna bother to stop
the recording so we have a perfect
situation
life ain't perfect I'ma keep going
because you need this lesson like some
people need life at times right so
you go into a conversation at zero when
you say I need to talk to you about
something instead I want you to think of
it this way when you go in at zero and
then you say what's go what's wrong I
need to talk to you this doesn't work
for me this doesn't work for me every
time you say this doesn't work for me
you go down one notch negative one
negative two negative three right most
people do that almost everyone does that
look we need to talk as soon as you say
that people like oh what and then you go
on to all the things that doesn't work
that don't work for you right
well that takes them down negative one
negative two negative three you never
get back up which is why brain splatter
ends up on the ceiling because you can
never get up to neutral again
you you start it and you took them down
and you you guys couldn't get back out
let's try this so I want you to get a
piece of paper out and I want you to
write zero and draw a line like like
it's a it's a it's a guiding line and
write zero right in the center of that
line and then write negative one
negative two negative 3 below the line
instead of starting with I need to talk
about something and going into what's
wrong I want you to start every
challenging conversation
and I want you to take them up plus them
think about it plus three me plus three
me
plus three me right which means
I need to talk to you about something
first of all what I want to tell you is
what I love about you plus one
what I respect about you is
plus two
what I appreciate and honor you for
plus three
what I realize is that I'm really
complete with this relationship there
are parts of it that's not serving me
anymore and it's time for me to move on
plus two
I need to love you from a distance I
just need space
plus one
and um
I need that space to begin now
zero
still a hard conversation but now you've
ended at Zero versus negative three
still not easy to have I didn't say it
was going to be easy but when you plus
three me
you actually add value and add energy to
who I am and affirming me because even
in the worst relationship even in the
most negative situation you can find
things to love people for to appreciate
them for and to honor them for and then
they're the things that doesn't that
don't work
plus three me and then course correct me
plus three me and then complete with me
plus three me before you do anything
else so in any conversation with a
co-worker with a child with a loved one
with the romance a romantic interest
with a friend plus three me and then
let's manage what can be fixed adjusted
or shifted in our relationship
remember this is not a monologue no way
Jose I am not interested in being the
only person talking here I want to hear
from you your words mean everything I
think what makes this channel so unique
and so delicious and so Dynamic is the
conversations that we have in chat
around the videos around the messages I
would love to hear from you
what conversation have you had in the
past and you needed this technique what
conversation is up for you to have in
the future and you are so glad that you
now have this technique remember
plus three me plus plus plus then go
down and course correct most importantly
in every conversation remember to leave
their dignity intact that's what you owe
not them but that's what you owe the
person that you've committed to being
every single thing you touch is impacted
by your story as an attorney as a
teacher as an architect there is not one
line of business that you can be in that
a story and a great story won't elevate
your outcome every single line of
business every single line of service
that you're connected to will be
impacted and ideally elevated by the
level in which you're willing to tell
and share your story so let me give you
some guidelines some parameters what I
like to call the bumper rails as if
you're going bowling you know when I go
bowling I ask them to put the little
bumper rails down so I can stay my ball
can get down the lane so let me set up
some bumper rails for you so that you
understand what makes a great story
so one is the willingness to take risk
most people Vision when they're telling
a story they don't want to take a risk
so the story has it has its limits on
how high it'll go or how deep it'll go
and when you have that then you're
really not at that part that's going to
touch my soul so being willing to take a
risk being clear and concise with your
stories a great story is a show me story
not a Tell me story now this is the
distinction that's the game changer for
most most people are telling a story
they say
um so let me just share with you a
little bit of my story and I'll tell you
and then I'll show you
so as I was building my life there was a
time in my life that was very difficult
it was very challenging true story very
difficult very challenging very
uncomfortable I didn't have a lot of
money I didn't have a lot of Hope and
things just looked dismal at some point
I had to turn my life around at some
point I made the decision that life had
to get better I'm telling you that it's
decent you learn about me then if I were
to show you that story I would say six
days a week
I had to eat beanies and weenies I had
to find money in the crevices in the
corners of my couch so that I can get my
sun milk
there were times when my heart would
beat fast just said what am I going to
have tomorrow
at some point I got sick and tired of my
own story is this going to be my future
no I can't handle it notice a difference
in that second story I completely see
that I just painted a picture same story
now the second one when you show a story
it's gonna require more of you it's
going to require you to find the colors
what were you thinking what were you
experiencing what was going on in your
head instead of telling me you look for
money turn and point now this is
anywhere this is anywhere you are doing
anything I promise you you become a
great Storyteller and you will Captivate
your audience no matter what you're
doing I've captivated investors I've
captivated students I've captivated
Educators because I was willing to show
the story I call it unpacking the story
Vision being willing to tell me what
were you thinking what were you feeling
what were you saying think about a story
as an oral movie and so in an oral movie
think when you look in a movie the first
thing they do is they identify what
state of time it is is it futuristic is
it in the now was it back in the day you
notice that based on what people are
wearing how they're talking so paint
that that picture for me take me to that
environment set the backdrop up for me
show me what you're going through
instead of saying I was angry you can
tell me you're angry but when you say
the hair on the back of my neck was
standing up I felt the fumes exiting my
nose I thought that my chest was going
to pop and I was going to say something
that I'd regret forever
oh you just showed me you were angry
take that extra time to unpack it why
will most people not do that
because it requires a level of
vulnerability that we're not willing to
share when you look at prioritizing it
really lives in an imma say this word
and you're probably not going to want to
hear it but when I tell you it's a game
changer when you master and just for now
begin to operate inside of time
management I used to resist time
management because I'm a I'm a free
spirit slash people will call me a rebel
back in the day meaning I didn't want to
be controlled I wanted I'm a butterfly I
wanted to I want it to soar I wanted to
be free well the reality is that when
you manage your time more effectively
you actually create more freedom that
was a huge I have to be somebody's going
to be ol right now like Breakthrough out
loud because when you time manage
meaning I'm going to use better blocks
of my time let me give you some examples
for that I'm gonna use better blocks of
my time meaning I'm only going to go in
my email three times a day I go on my
email about 9 30 between 9 20 and 9 40.
I go on my email I stand my email for 30
minutes I'll go back in my email about
three o'clock in the afternoon I stay in
my email again for about 30 minutes I go
back on my email one more time at 6 PM I
stay in for about 30 minutes that's it I
don't go in 19 times I don't go in 20
times because three times a day gives me
adequate time to see what's in there see
what's new
ly otherwise it's throwing me off I I
time block my day about 90 minutes each
time block to do a task even if a task
only takes me 30 minutes I time block 90
minutes because I get distracted but
when you time block your your day and
then you schedule each day not every day
looks the same I have a Time block for
everything I need to do for seven days
out the week can you believe that in
that time I got more things done you
have to become comfortable with your no
my grandmother says baby she starts
every sentence with baby baby if you
want your yes to have more value you
need to learn how to exercise your no
see your yes might not have its value
anymore why because you give it away too
much you give it to too many people you
give it away too often you're always
over committing and then you feel
drained and frustrated and you don't
have gratitude in your heart because
you're over committed well that all
started with a yes that should have been
enough or should have been a I'd love to
but not now
and so number two number one is more
effective time management that has your
agenda in it it has your prior
priorities in it right now your agenda
is covered with everyone else's task I
often I heard once if you don't have
your agenda then you're going to work
for somebody else's agenda and so number
one is your time manager with your
agenda and number two is operating
utilizing and being comfortable in a no
and not an attitude no not for like a
saint no like no not that just uh no not
now no I I I would love to but my plate
is full I'm free in 90 days
just don't make no no energy just not
now don't be surprised when everyone
comes to you you're great you're amazing
you're brilliant look at you you're on
this channel so you know you're smart
you want your better life you want an
abundant life of course you're here of
course everyone wants you and your
priorities matter so the third thing is
to remember it's your job to fill your
own name it's your job to fulfill your
own dreams it's your job to write the
story that you're going to want to read
it's your job so the responsibility of
your dreams coming true does not belong
to your husband does not belong to your
man does not belong to your woman or to
your children so to to wait and hope for
them to one day see your dream as a
priority that's an unrealistic
expectation and actually it's unfair
it's your priority and what that looks
like is carving out time that looks like
what doing it on the agenda it looks
like declaring it out loud so that the
world could hear it looks like giving
yourself a chance
a thousand chances
and pressing reset if you happen to fall
down or sit down or get distracted so if
you want to know what does it mean to
keep your priorities Your Dreams a
priority it starts with you it starts
right now it starts right here
I know what it feels like to prioritize
other people over my dream I did it for
years I love being loved I love love and
I love being loved and I used to say yes
all the time just to be loved and I
realized that I was teaching the people
around me how to treat me
that you teach the people around you how
to treat you so if they're treating you
as if your life isn't a priority your
dreams are a priority it's because
you've taught them how to treat you that
way I know ouch
Lisa dang I know it stings it's things
when I say it it stings me when I say
but the reality is if you train them how
to treat you
then you can retrain them how to treat
me now
and so and it's not a matter of making
any big announcements it starts with
just setting some healthy boundaries
it's starting with making some time
management it starts by making sure you
continue to come back here and that we
stay connected and that you allow me or
someone else to help navigate you
through the terrain called designing a
better life the one that you love the
one that you're you admire and so let's
start with those things because that'll
make a huge difference in your life in
that year when I was really broken I was
really broken I was working at La
Unified School District
I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a j-o-b and
then one day
I said well what what do I need to do I
I need to I need to buy my freedom
that's what I need to do I need to buy
my freedom well I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burning my pocket so I
know two things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day I spent so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
God it's like I'm feeding like a family
of ten because I'm so afraid of anybody
ever being in my house and being hungry
right
and so I I wrote a check to myself
Jelani was three
hundred and ten dollars
took it to the bank
Wells Fargo
started a new account
the next check I wrote
125 dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the memo line funding my dream I wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District and no
disrespect to La Unified School District
it just wasn't my destiny
I wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding my dream
now I started mailing the checks in
because I didn't want to see my balance
because I didn't want to go shopping
because I you're gonna repeat what you
learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so I mailed the check in and I wrote
another check and I wrote another check
and every check I wrote I made sure it
was five percent more than the first
check the net the previous check I sold
my Altima I had a car note sold my
Optical bought a clunker because it
didn't have a car note now I can write a
bigger check funding my dream
I moved out of my three bedroom three
bath three bath house and moved in
became a roommate with my friend who
smoked I put towels at the base of the
door so the smoke wouldn't come to the
door I was willing to be inconvenienced
are you yes yes I'm just saying I'm just
I'm just showing you the story I just
the charge I just gave you I stopped
getting my hair done that was when I
started going natural
I stopped going out
I I stopped going out dancing I stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my God you know it was La she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
I don't know what's going on
I kept writing bigger checks to myself
nine hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
I mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was
I just knew I had one
and it was being born through me
and I needed to give it a chance
that's all I knew you don't have to see
2 000 feet in front of you just see 200.
and run to the 200.
you'll have to see it all
three and a half years later I've
written a check to myself every two
weeks for three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and a half
years I didn't go dancing I didn't get
my hair done I did get my nails done for
three and a half years are you willing
to be inconvenienced for your conviction
I walk in to Wells Fargo three and a
half years later
and I said hi God bless you hi
my name is Lisa Nichols she goes oh my
gosh
you're the fun in my dream lady I was
like yeah I guess I am and all of a
sudden all the tellers came running
around the manager came they're like oh
my God okay oh my God we have been
wondering we all got the same question
y'all know what the question is right
what's your dream
I was like
um
I'm not sure
but I know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
having to be willing to give themselves
a thousand Second Chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
I'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just gonna help people
I said I came to check my balance I've
been writing a few checks to you guys to
say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just wanted to check my
balances you don't know your balance I
said no I got this really big stack of
summary bank statements at home because
my mama said money Burns her pockets and
I don't want it to burn my pocket I
wanted to pay for my freedom
I said I just came to see what my
balance was if I had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clear
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me I
looked at it I said oh no my name is
Lisa Shantae Nichols and my social
security number I said that is not my
money and I am not taking that money
because you're probably gonna want it
back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
I said you really don't think that's
yours
I said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank or ten
thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream is
I think you can fund it now
I looked at my son Jelani who now was
five or six and I said Jelani
our lives are going to be a little
different now baby
Jelani said yeah
Mommy can we
can't we now go to McDonald's
[Music]
see for three years I've been telling
you Lonnie I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so I don't know what yours is I don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet the next
best step this is the first step and so
I just stopped by to let you know you're
on the right path
and and as you ramp up as you ramp up
you're going to have questions you're
going to be afraid I do more things
afraid now than I do Fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdown
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney
like they're just big because I'm
playing big
I'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great life don't just go to the edge and
feel it
be willing to lean
fill your heartbeat
feel it that'll let you know you're
alive
to let you know you're okay fear fuels
you fear lets you know go get more
information fear let you know step a
little later and study fear let you know
get up a little earlier fear let you
know ask for help fear is informing you
it's not stopping you it's just another
emotion like love and compassion and
gratitude we just made it paralyze us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm gonna
love anyway I feel it and I'm going to
invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
going to show up and play anyway when
you get connected with fear it becomes
your best friend and when you stand on
the edge
oh
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway you know so many
times people
um look at the habits that they have
such as procrastination and ask why do I
procrastinate well I pose that question
back to you ask yourself what's the
benefit because there's a benefit that
you're getting out of it so whether you
believe that last minute throws you
inside of an energy source because
that's what I used to think I spent last
minute I'm more creative well the truth
is you're not more creative last minute
the truth is that when you wait to the
last minute you're increasing your
stress level you're bringing down your
joy you're eliminating peace of mind
when you understand the cost
procrastination is a word and and the
challenge is that procrastination is so
universally accepted it's like fear and
stress
like I'm so stressed out and it's become
such our Norm that it's okay well ask
yourself the question what's the price
that I pay because I believe any
behavior that you don't want any longer
the way that the Catalyst to change is
recognizing the price because we're High
producers we can still get it done
inside of procrastinating we can still
get it done but if you ever take a
moment to stop and ask yourself and
answer what's the cost
of me procrastinating and you can do
that for everything but we're focused on
procrastination now what's the cost of
me procrastinating let's go down that
list
when you procrastinate it costs you
clear organizational time because now
you're rushing when you procrastinate it
costs you peace of mind when you
procrastinate you're now thrown in
urgency
urgency increases your stress
urgency is known to increase your stress
if you live in urgency you literally are
two three times more likely to have a
heart attack I hear not confirmed but
that's what I heard so if you live in
this pace of urgency all the time
because of a behavior that you can
modify
think about it how are we forward moving
utterly mobile how are we brilliant and
operating in something we can control
there's so many things that you can't
control procrastination is something
that you can control I used to be last
minute and I resisted I got to tell you
I resisted planning I thought that it
was for Slackers I didn't need to plan I
can I can go off the fly and I'm pretty
creative and I can get myself out of
some pretty hairy situations and I can
produce pretty good content pretty good
experiences last minute so I lived in
the last minute conversation I didn't
even call a procrastination it was just
when it was scheduled to be done so if
I'm flying out at noon I can pack at
seven in the morning
when I realized that I eliminated the
space that I needed to do it in such a
planned methodical way that on the other
side I felt good about it when you wait
to the last minute to do anything you've
now taken the joy away that comes with
having the space to do it in a timeline
that's effective but here's the other
thing
I ask you what are you proving to
yourself
when you can get it done at the last
minute what are you proving to yourself
because there's some form of proving or
denying or
there's something going on that you
still need to do especially if you know
how to plan in other areas of your life
you can't be a part-time planner
part-time strategist part-time person
who's prepared and then in this other
area you're not no now you're making a
choice so why do you choose to
procrastinate what do you believe it's
giving you and if you found out that
it's not really giving you what you
thought it's giving you or if you found
out that procrastination has given you a
whole lot more than you bargained for
it's giving you stress it's giving you
the the non-gift of urgency it's giving
you all these things that you go oh I
didn't know all that comes with it yeah
and the challenges you manage all that
well
and because you manage it well you think
it's okay to have it
can we give you more peace of mind
I packed the same exact clothes for a
trip I simply packed for the trip 72
hours in advance so the final 72 hours
that I have I can use that relaxing or I
can use that planning something else but
when I'm in urgency packing and I've
been there plenty of times
I lose the creativity I lose the peace
of mind and I lose a little bit of Joy
because now I'm bumped up against a
deadline that's so intense and it's a
non-negotiable deadline if I back away
from that deadline and I give space and
Grace and ease it actually is a form of
self-love I know that sounds crazy that
planning and not procrastinating is a
form of self-love but see when you
procrastinate you're putting that thing
you need to do last which really is
putting you last again so if you
procrastinate you're putting yourself
last it's not the only time you put
yourself last it's a behavior and a
habit that you do so I ask can you move
yourself up to the top you might not put
yourself first but can you put yourself
second
I'm a shoot for first procrastination
and overcoming progression I'm you're
talking to a recovery recovering
procrastinator
that when I moved from procrastination
to better planning
I felt the grace and ease in space in my
life
still had the same hours in the day
I just organized them differently
I just set better priorities more
effective priorities
that you're not supposed to enjoy
you're not supposed to enjoy the
experience when you get there
you're supposed to enjoy the experience
and the journey getting there
and when you move from procrastination
to planning to time management and time
management is a fact time management is
a direct has a direct impact on
procrastination if it matters to you it
should find its way in your calendar it
should find its way when I'm going on a
trip I have pack I have packed in my
calendar I have a pack in my calendar
four days before I'm leaving so that if
I run out of time and it takes me a
whole day to get to packing I'm still
three days early
it took a long time to learn that
procrastination is showing up for you
last
are you willing to show up for you first
are you willing to trust if you can do a
good job at the last minute what can you
do if you planned it out in a more
effective way what can you do if you
just live this next season on what could
I do if I search for the best and
brightest version of myself
procrastination will be on the list of
one of the things you modified to
discover the best and brightest and most
brilliant version of yourself Christy
talked about affirmations abundant
thinkers understand the power of I am
anything after the word I am is true to
your unconscious mind Michael anything
anything after I am anything anything
after I am even if you just you know
it's not true your conscious mind will
believe it anything after I am so the
use of affirmations is very intentional
and very consistent
I was diagnosed as clinically depressed
and two
Thousand and One
1998 I'm sorry I was diagnosed as
clinically depressed
me it didn't make sense I had been in a
relationship I was engaged to get
married and my fiance
um who I did not know at the time uh was
bipolar and he'd stopped taking his
medicines and under the belief system
that love can cure anything
and so I ended up being picked up and
thrown three feet across the room
and I ended up being choked until I
passed out and once I got out of that
relationship I just was different it was
different
so my mom insisted that I go to the
doctor I went to the doctor and I sat on
the table
and she checked me and talked to me and
came back in with a prescription
and she said Alisa you're clinically
depressed and I felt like I heard
Charlie Brown's parents talking like
want want clinically depressed at least
don't make sense in that same sentence
and she handed me a prescription and I
read the prescription and had my name on
it and it said Prozac I thought that
don't make sense Lisa Nichols Pro that
don't make sense and I said
do you mean I'm sad
she said very very sad
I said can I try something and I'm not
I'm not uh recommending you guys if
you're on medication you stop taking
your meds please don't do that I asked
my doctor she agreed I said do you mind
if I try something before I take this
she goes yes but I need to see you back
in 30 days if you're in the same
condition I need us to try this medicine
I said okay I could do that so I went
home
and every day I got in the mirror
and I drilled I am
every day because I realized I have
forgotten who I was
I I just forgot I just and it was okay
to forget I just forgot so every day
every day for 25 minutes I just went
over the I AMS every day I am I am I am
and then I I parallel that what I
forgive you for then I parallel that
what I commit to you Lisa every single
day I went back in 30 days and I'm
talking to her and I'm on fire she's
just looking at me I'm just talking
talking she Twisted her head again and
I'm just talking talking she says wait I
gotta stop you I said what she goes what
are you taking and can I have some
I was like I'm taking some of me and so
the power of I am and the power of I am
can pull you through the darkest moment
the power of I am because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
if you want another amazing Lisa Nichols
video check it out right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there